recruter ses salariés localement c'est
la démarche de cette société de conseil
et de services en informatique créée à
montigny au début des années 90 et qui
depuis a connu une croissance fulgurante
nos clients sont très sensibles au fait
que les ingénieurs habite pas très loin
ne soit pas très gêné par les transports
le tissu local est aussi assez
intéressant les diversités donc de
versailles saint quentin et des écoles
qui s'implantent dont nous aussi nous
cherchons à faire vivre ce tissu local
parce que nous y croyons c'est une
société c'est une ville nouvelle donc
intéressante donc pour ça que c'est
intéressant que tout le monde puisse il
travaille et les vivants passé de 250 à
700 salariés après le rachat l'été
dernier de la filiale française d'un
groupe américain la société a installé
son siège à paris tout en conservant un
service recherche et développement de 25
personnes à guyancourt une antenne en
fort développement puisque 50 postes
sont ouverts au recrutement
profil recherché des bac + 5 issus
d'écoles d'ingénieurs ou de l'université
une première expérience est demandé mais
pas nécessaire softeam possède en effet
une université en interne
l'avenir semble radieux pour la pm
devenue grande entreprise qui table à
présent sur un développement
international
nous avons des projets effectivement
d'internationalisation plutôt du côté
asie pour accompagner nos grands clients
certains de nos grands clients du
domaine de la finance sont évidemment
sur paris mais aussi on pense à l'ombre
dont on pense aussi à hong kong
singapour notamment une demande d
accompagner softeam compte plusieurs
centaines de clients aux profils divers
de la banque aux grands groupes
industriels en passant par les
assurances
elle recrute chaque année en moyenne 150
à 200 personnes